das ist nicht nur ein straßenkonzert
sondern auch ein test mit einem typisch
deutschen ergebnis kaum einer bleibt
stehen
dabei weiß rosa stark dass das auch
anders geht während ihres aufenthaltes
in kalifornien waren die reaktionen auf
ihr geigenspiel wesentlich euphorischer
das ist ein echtes highlight wenn jemand
stehen bleibt und was nettes sagt oder
jedes gespräch sucht das ist schon
passiert so einmal die stunde vielleicht
wie wäre es in kalifornien als er
gespielt hat
da warst du dass du alle anderthalb
minuten jemand kam und mir gesagt hat so
vielen dank dass sie mir spielen
wie gesagt hätte ich mir gerade den
abend erst richtig durch gelaufen und
jetzt was mich das kalkuliert und jetzt
kann ich irgendwie wieder glücklich nach
hause gehen oder so und ganz auf
bedanken sich die leute oder sagen dass
die kinder von huth spiel
diese erfahrung haben sie zu ihrem blog
inspiriert ein kompliment denn seit
einem halben jahr betreibt sie ihnen
verbreitet damit nicht nur lob und
anerkennung sondern auch gute laune denn
komplimente sind in deutschland eher
selten
umso mehr freuen sich die menschen diese
junge frau bekam in der u-bahn ein
kompliment für ihre schönheit ihr
musiklehrer dafür dass er an sie glaubt
dieses paar fürs outfit und der kiosk
besitzer für den beeindruckenden watt
ich habe wahnsinnig viel gelernt ich
habe unglaublich viele erfahrungen
gemacht und geschichten gehört und
freunde gefunden die ich sonst nicht
viel gelernt hat so das hat natürlich
schon mal von meinem leben ich habe mich
verändert insofern als dass ich weiß
mittlerweile selbst in deutschland wenn
ich auf leute zugehen und mich überwinde
lohnt sich das immer wirklich immer bis
jetzt eine coole begegnung geworden ist
wobei es natürlich große kulturelle
unterschiede gibt nicht wie also ständig
vor ein italiener hat ein ganz anderes
verhältnis zum komplimente machen als
der skandinavier hatte er etwas
reservierter nüchterner ist aber
wahrhaftig ist dafür
italiener oder wir können griechen eben
auch ein lateinamerikaner nehmen der
sieht das anders ein kompliment ist ein
teil der interaktion der kommunikation
mit dem anderen und da kann man schon
mal ein bisschen auch auftragen und ein
bisschen was übertreiben
mittlerweile ist rosa stark immer auf
der suche um jemandem etwas nettes zu
sagen denn das macht ihr selbst auf gute
laune
das schönste kompliment mit der besten
geschichte des tages veröffentlicht sie
dann mit einem foto auf dem platz ihr
fällt das mittlerweile ganz leicht mir
nicht und genau deshalb will ich es
ausprobieren
kannst du mir einen tipp geben das
kompliment die selber super fahren oder
nicht
wichtig ist dass du fühlst und macht den
kopf einfach aus und denkt nicht so viel
darüber nach mit versteckter kamera
begebe ich mich auf die mission und muss
ganz schön über meinen schatten springen
sprechen sie englisch ich wollte ihnen
nur sagen dass ich ihren makeln danach
ist der damm gebrochen
großartig aus ich mag keine mütze dies
wirklich lustig ich mag komplimente
bei gut gelaufen touristen kein problem
schwieriger wird es in einer deutschen
fußgängerzone spontane komplimente sind
hier exotischen die reaktion
zurückhaltend finde sie als partner
sehen ganz lässig und sehr sympathisch
aus dafür dass sie gerade ihrer mutter
so nett geholfen haben möchte ich
eigentlich der mutter ein kompliment
machen dass sie ihren sohn so gut
erzogen haben habe ich ihr ein
kompliment machen
nein ich darf ihn kein kompliment machen
ich wollte etwas nettes sagen ich finde
die farbe von ihrer hose die ich sehr
sehr toll ja die sehr cool
wir haben keine so entwickelte
komplimente kultury kompliment kultur
wie in den süden europas aber wir haben
müssen natürlich auch wie man
komplimente macht und ich glaube der
gilt bei vielen deutschen ist dieses
eine kleine zurückhaltung auch im
ausdruck dass sie ehrlich gemeint sind
rosa stark wertet mittlerweile ihre
komplimente für den block aus und heute
fällt ihre wahl auf uns auch das team
der deutschen welle
danke denn wer es wagt komplimente zu
verteilen er bekommt eben mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit 1 zurück